We mentioned previously CAMPS.
The first letter letter stands for
Culture.
What does that mean?
Huge inspiration for DevOps, is Agile.
And one of Agile's key points is,
people over process over tools.
You can have the most efficient product,
development, operations, and marketing
teams in the world, but if they do not
communicate, there's no feedback or
collaboration between teams, it can lead
to a huge waste of time and resources.
Lean is also a major inspiration for
DevOps culture.
Lean is centered on streamlining
operations, reducing waste,
with the end goal of
maximizing customer value.
Improving separate points in
the production pipeline is not enough,
you have to improve the whole flow.
Ever hear the phrase hurry up and wait?
Reminds me of traveling
on international flights.
Having a faster silo doesn't really
help in getting me to the plane quicker.
I usually just end up
waiting in the next line.
This is also true for DevOps.
If we focus on our
customers as the main goal,
it becomes an easy common ground for
all concerned parties.
A great culture is also important,
fostering respect.
You can also call it hug ops.
When you can understand and you can
empathize on both Dev and Ops teams,
you can really focus your
energies on positive outcomes.
Usually known as going to work thinking
how can I make this harder, but
there are various reasons
as to why it happens.